there now a village in western germany's
r valley
there's a lot of debris to clear away
before the residents can begin
rebuilding
well sometimes it's a bit wobbly around
here
it may be great but not so well
organized dernal streets are the site of
many unusual traffic jams he saw images
of the havoc the floods had wreaked on
tv and wanted to pitch in
business friends lent him this tractor
and trailer for free
in july the river r became a raging
torrent devastating the valley and the
villagers in it in the are alone over
130 people lost their lives hundreds
were injured now over 40 kilometers of
the ah valley are one long construction
site thousands of tons of debris have to
be hauled away
it's rubbish and mud a space was cleared
early on where we could dump everything
now we use wheel excavators to separate
the materials
now the 58 year old father is operating
heavy equipment along the r
he says this is where he's spending his
vacation and he's not the only one
from north or south east or west from
austria switzerland and the netherlands
we're all working together that's really
great it may be great but not well
organized denial streets are the site of
many unusual traffic jams
they want to load dirt in the front here
we're loading up stuff for the dump back
there
everything has to pass along this narrow
road it causes a lot of waiting time
then at last it's his turn to load up
normally i transport 16 tons but he
filled it so full there must be at least
20 tons
but the traffic laws don't count here
anyway
everyone drives whatever and however
they can
as chaotic as it looks the residents are
grateful for the volunteers and their
help some have brought their
semi-trailer trucks while others report
to wine growers like alina zontag to
wash the dirt off the many wine bottles
and barrels in this traditionally wine
producing region
an extremely great feat has been
accomplished the past few weeks
we've managed to clear out all the
cellars the barrels are back in place
that never would have been possible if
the volunteers hadn't been here
but there are limits to what the
volunteers in the r valley can achieve
the damaged infrastructure is a job for
the authorities the repairs will take
years
even so the volunteers contribution is
vital
adversity brings people together
and being there for others
[Music]
and the appreciation and gratitude
people show in return
is a really fantastic experience to be
having right now
you don't get much of that otherwise in
everyday life
the volunteers tasks in the disaster
area are not without risk and the
helpers in the r valley are also
volunteering to face that risk
nobody knows what has been washed into
the mud here
the floodwaters carried everything down
with them from higher up
materials from households agricultural
chemicals from the wine growers oil from
tanks
there's lots and lots of waste in it and
nobody knows what it is
when it turns to dust
we breathe it all in here
isn't even thinking of quitting if
anything he's considering extending his
vocation in the r valley by a few more
days
you